[Música]
qué es lo que mantiene a un león
encerrado en su caja
hoy por la tarde no voy a poder
responder a muchas preguntas pero quizá
esta sea la única que tenga respuesta
cuando yo era pequeño mi padre no sabía
llevar a los multicines del barrio a ver
sesiones matinales los fines de semana
pero en lugar de llevarnos a ver
blancanieves mary poppins o cantinflas
mi padre con un criterio pedagógico
bastante cuestionable nos lleva a ver
películas de ciencia ficción blade
runner atmósfera 0 2001 1 dice en el
espacio yo por supuesto no entendía
prácticamente nada de lo que estaba
pasando ahí pero quedé maravillado
quiere alucine con las posibilidades
tecnológicas que se planteaban en esas
películas tanto es así que estudiando la
brasa en casa todo el rato para
conseguir tener un ordenador y con nueve
años mi madre me compro mi primer
ordenador y desde entonces no me ha
apartado de ellos pasé un montón de años
aprendiendo a programar es decir
aprendiendo a decirle al ordenador cómo
quería que me ayudara a resolver los
problemas
y tiempo después visitan un amigo el
hermano mayor de mi amigo manu me dijo
que estaba investigando en una cosa que
se llamaba la inteligencia artificial o
la guía y me contó que en lugar de
explicar el ordenador qué pasos tiene
que seguir para resolver un problema él
estaba desarrollando un juego del tres
en raya y simplemente había explicado al
ordenador cuáles eran las reglas del 3
central ya pueden ser los movimientos
que se podían hacer y había dejado al
programa jugando contra sí mismo durante
un montón de horas y al cabo de ese
tiempo había conseguido tener un jugador
de tres en raya que era totalmente
imbatible los robots humanoides de blade
runner o el superordenador jal de 2001
son ejemplos de lo que se conoce como la
inteligencia general la inteligencia
artificial general o fuerte los
programas que son capaces de enfrentarse
a cualquier problema y resolverlo de
forma bastante inteligente mientras que
el jueguito de tres en raya de mi amigo
manu pues es un ejemplo de lo que se
conoce como inteligencia artificial
débil o estrecha
son programas que saben hacer solamente
una cosa y la saben hacer muy bien un
ejemplo de esto lo tenemos también en la
en el vuelo que hubo mítico a finales de
los 90 entre el supercomputador deep
blue y el campeón mundial del ajedrez
gary kasparov a pesar de los resquemores
de la guerra fría y de las banderitas
americana y rusa encima de la mesa
muchísimos estadounidenses confesaron
que quería que ganara gary kasparov
porque entendieron el duelo como una
batalla entre la inteligencia de los
humanos y la inteligencia de las
máquinas perdimos y creo que no vamos a
volver a ganar al ajedrez a una máquina
en lo que queda de nuestra historia y
bueno a este resquemores está frente a
nuestra inteligencia despertó un poco el
debate sobre los potenciales peligros de
la inteligencia artificial yo como bien
han dicho soy profesor y lo que traigo
aquí no son respuestas sino un montón de
preguntas pues la primera pregunta que
me planteo es qué impacto va a tener la
inteligencia artificial en el empleo ya
hemos visto qué impacto ha tenido la
robotización la mecanización en muchos
empleos manuales pero la inteligencia
artificial
ha venido para encargarse de los
trabajos también intelectuales que son
fácilmente definibles y repetitivos
monótonos pensemos que parte de nuestro
trabajo diario tiene algo de eso y quizá
venga una inteligencia artificial para
quitarlo os animo a que os forméis en
otros campos si ese es vuestro caso
porque quizá pues tengamos que dar una
vuelta a todo esto pero bueno
realmente eso es una apuesta que puede
darse o no porque somos los humanos muy
malos definiendo cuáles son nuestros
deseos la fábula del rey midas es un
perfecto recordatorio a veces le diremos
a la máquina que queremos una cosa y
realmente no era eso lo que queríamos si
la cosa se va muy de madre si perdemos
el control siempre podremos apagar la
máquina siempre podemos pulsar el botón
rojo soltar el cable tirar el servidor
por la ventana o lo que haga falta para
que eso termine pero estaremos de
acuerdo todas y todos en que queremos
prescindir de las ventajas de la
inteligencia artificial
además en un entorno en el que casi todo
está en la nube será tan fácil apagar un
solo ordenador o estar a esa
inteligencia artificial distribuida ya
por miles o millones de dispositivos
tampoco me quiero ponerme catastrofista
hay mucha gente que dice que preocuparse
por los peligros de la inteligencia
artificial es como preocuparse por la
superpoblación en marte no estamos allí
vale así que hoy estamos hablar para
hablar de diversidad y ese es
precisamente el mayor problema que le
veo a la inteligencia artificial hoy en
día la inteligencia artificial está
llena de sesgos es toma decisiones sobre
un montón de cuestiones muy importantes
en nuestra vida hablamos de sectores
como la educación la sanidad el empleo
la banca las finanzas están gestionadas
muchas veces por decisiones automáticas
y esas decisiones automáticas hay que
controlarlas hay que supervisar las
y entonces hay gente que dice bueno pues
hagamos que esas inteligencias
artificiales sean código abierto sean
software libre y podamos ver si tienen
algún fallo de programación pero
precisamente este software es lo
suficientemente difícil diferente al
resto como para que el programa casi no
importe los programas como como veíamos
con mi amigo a mano y el juego el tres
en raya son simplemente una serie de
reglas muy sencillas que sirven para
aprender dónde está el problema el
problema está en los datos los datos que
alimentan a estas inteligencias
artificiales para enseñarles cómo tienen
que tomar decisiones y esos datos
irónicamente son datos del pasado son
datos que provienen de lo que ya hemos
hecho y cómo es nuestro pasado habéis
creado alguna vez en el tiempo reciente
una revista o un periódico de hace 20 30
40 años sobre todo la sección de
publicidad es un compendio de todos los
ismos que se nos puedan ocurrir no hay
clasismo racismo sexismo y cualquier
otra cosa eso es lo que está alimentando
las inteligencias artificiales nuestro
pasado entonces yo lo que sugiero es que
tengamos un poco de cuidado con que dad
son el combustible de las inteligencias
artificiales que vayamos a utilizar el
problema no está en que la inteligencia
artificial se nos vaya de las manos el
problema está en que nosotros tenemos
que tener un poco de cuidado con eso
y la tecnología en general no es
moralmente neutra y por eso hay mucha
gente que sugiere que podemos definir
una capa por debajo de las inteligencias
artificiales una especie de sistema
operativo o moral que les impida tomar
decisiones que sean moralmente
discutibles eso tecnológicamente es muy
difícil de hacer
me gustaría que pasara pero no lo veo
tan tan próximo
desde la universidad deusto como ya
hemos comentado hemos desarrollado un
debate hemos hemos abierto un debate con
nuestra declaración de derechos humanos
digitales que os animo a leer ya
compartir porque porque creo que esto no
es un cataclismo no es algo que nos
venga ya pero es algo que deberíamos
reflexionar empezaba diciendo que qué es
lo que mantiene a un león en su caja o
en su jaula encerrado pues un león es
mucho más fuerte mucho más rápido tiene
mejor oído mejor olfato mejor tiene unas
garras que nos podrían destrozar en
segundos es nuestra inteligencia lo
único que mantiene al león encerrado en
su jaula y como quiero acabar con un
mensaje positivo
me gustaría deciros que confío en
nuestra inteligencia para qué
este león será todavía en su jaula
muchas gracias